is not tell if this is
actually
working okay so is this getting Audio Oh
that's
looks like it
is not tell if this is
actually oh yeah yeah okay I see the
echo cool um I mute
this and the latency is
like 15 seconds or something that's not
bad that's like
lower how much is this frying my PO old
laptop
really like oh wait no here it is yeah
there is temp
um okay so I think I'm just going to
chill for a
moment see how high the temps get
cuz
75c on gaming laptop is
if this is stable or if it just jumps
way
up most of the demos are not going to be
running I still have the zoom meeting
open yeah so that's a fair
SP but it looks like machine is handling
it
fine the audio quality is stable or if
it just jumps way
up audio quality is good actually
stream quality
10860 yeah okay
well I think we're pretty well set
then
uh so I guess I set this to go
live a little bit before
tomorrow and we should be
good
co and the test